here are 5 unique volunteer opportunity ideas
that I guarantee you haven't thought of before!
these ideas are perfect for a high
schooler that needs to complete their volunteer hours.
or just a college student.
an adult who wants to make a difference in their lives
but doesn't know how first.
we just got through the holiday season.
here's a way you can turn a holiday party
or a birthday party
into something that actually helps people.
host a party
with a twist!
instead of everyone bringing a gift for you,
bring a gift for children in your
local foster care network.
number 2 organize a restaurant benefit night.
1t of restaurants will actually do
nights where they will give a portion of their proceeds
for everyone who comes in
or for the people that you bring in
towards whatever cause you're working for.
so if you have a local haunt that everybody loves,
approach them.
organize it.
invite your friends.
money for a good cause.
done. number 3
do a community yard sale.
go through the neighborhood,
put up flyers,
knock on doors,
get people to donate
things that they don't want already.
and as you say,
another man's trash is another man's treasure.
not sure I got that right.
number 4 put on a hike for cause
if you're someone who loves to get outdoors.
if your friends like to get outdoors,
do it one day
with a little bit of a twist
to participate in the hike.
brings even $10
towards a cause that's close to your heart,
and all of a sudden,
you're hiking for a bit more than the views.
number 5 organize a sports tournament.
tennis, basketball,
volleyball, kickball.
something that everyone can participate in.
they pay an entry fee to participate,
and the money raised goes towards a great cost.
if you'd really want to do these ideas,
but feel overwhelmed and don't know where to start,
go to amoxit impact org.
apply as a high school student
or join our wait list.
if you're not in high school,
we are here to give you the support you need
to make a real impact.
follow for more.